>>> CONGRESSWOMAN LAUREN BOEBERT
IS COURTING MORE CONTROVERSY.
THE COLORADO REPUBLICAN TWEETED
THIS PICTURE LAST NIGHT SHOWING
HER FOUR BOYS HOLDING
SEMIAUTOMATIC GUNS.
YOU'LL REMEMBER THAT ONE OF HER
CONGRESS COLLEAGUES THOMAS
MASSEY MADE HEADLINES LAST WEEK
WITH A SIMILAR HOLIDAY PHOTO OF
HIS FAMILY.
>> HOUSE DEMOCRATS WERE ALREADY
CALLING FOR BOEBERT TO BE
DISCIPLINED FOR HER REPEATED
IS
ISLAM PHOBIC COMMENTS ABOUT
ILHAN OMAR.
I GOT TO READ SOME TWEETS
BECAUSE THERE'S A BACK AND FORTH
THAT'S RELEVANT HERE.
CONGRESSMAN ALEXANDRIA OC
OCASIO-CORTEZ RE-TWEETED THAT
PHOTO.
TELL ME WHERE CHRIST SAID USE
THE COMMEMORATION OF MY BIRTH,
ALL THE -- ERASING CHRISTMAS AND
ITS MEANING WHEN THEY'RE DOING
FINE ALL ON THEIR OWN.
AND THEN BOEBERT REPLIED WITH
AOC USES HER POSITION AS A
CONGRESSWOMAN TO ATTACK MY BOYS
WITH THEIR CHRISTMAS PRESENTS.
FIRST, I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A
GOOD IDEA FOR BOEBERT TO GO
ONLINE HERE AND ADMIT THAT HER
8-YEAR-OLD WHO'S NOT TALL ENOUGH
TO RIDE SPACE MOUNTAIN NOW HAS A
SEMIAUTOM
SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLE IF THOSE
GUNS ARE REAL.
THIS PLAYS RIGHT INTO WHAT
LAUREN BOEBERT WANTS.
THIS AOC BACK AND FORTH SEEMS
LIKE THE STRATEGY.
IT'S THE POINT OF PUTTING THE
PICTURE UP IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO SHIFT
THE CONVERSATION ON TO TERMS
THAT WE KNOW THAT THE
CONGRESSWOMAN BOEBERT WILL BE
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH.
THEY WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT GUNS.
THEY WANT TO MOVE THIS TO THE
CULTURE WAR ABOUT CHRISTMAS AND
ITS MEANING, AND WANTS TO IMPLY
THAT REPRESENTATIVE O ATTACKED R
CHILDREN.
WHICH THE TWEET DID NOT DO.
WHAT THE CONGRESSWOMAN SAID
ABOUT ILHAN OMAR WAS NATIVIST,
ISLAM PHOBIC, AND THAT IS WHAT
CAUSED THE REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN TO APOLOGIZE
HERSELF.
SHE ALREADY APOLOGIZED FOR THE
ACTION SHE TOOK INITIALLY.
THIS IS NOW AN ATTEMPT TO SWITCH
THE CONVERSATION FROM THAT BUT
WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE
REPUBLICANS WHO RATHER HAVE THE
TURF BE ON GUNS, BE ON
CHRISTMAS, BE ON THAT CULTURE
WAR THAN THE IDENTITY POLITICS
THAT THEY THEMSELVES ARE PLAYING
AND THAT ISLAMOPHOBIA,
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR HAD TO
EXPERIENCE.
>> TALK ABOUT THE WAR ON
CHRISTMAS, IS THERE ANY OTHER
BETTER EXHIBIT A THAN
BRANDISHING SEMIAUTOMATIC
WEAPONS.
WHERE IN THE BIBLE DOES IT SAY
BRANDISH YOUR WEAPONS IN HONOR
OF CHRIST'S BIRTHDAY, THAT'S
BASICALLY WHAT ALEXANDRIA O
O
OCASIO-CORTEZ WAS SAYING BUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING.
WHAT MASSEY HAS DONE AND
BOEBERT, IT'S SO FAR FROM THE
SPIRIT OF CHRIST.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY LAST READ
THEIR BIBLE IS, BUT THAT'S ONE
WAR ON CHRISTMAS THEY'RE TURNING
INTO THEIR BASTARDIZED VERSION
OF IT, BUT IT'S ALSO DAYS AFTER
A SCHOOL SHOOTING, YET ANOTHER
SCHOOL SHOOTING, HOW DO WE THINK
THE FAMILIES IN MICHIGAN FEEL
ABOUT THIS?
HOW DO WE THINK ALL OF THE
TRAUMATIZED STUDENTS, ALL OF THE
TRAUMATIZED DEPUTIES WHO HAD TO
SEE THE AFTER MATH OF THAT.
BEYOND ANY CULTURE WAR, JUST THE
INCREDIBLE INSENSITIVITY IS
REALLY STRIKING.
>> IT SHOWS THE NARROW FOCUS
THAT CONGRESSWOMAN BOEBERT IS
THINKING ABOUT.
ONLY THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
SWITCH THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
TERMS THAT SHE IS MORE
COMFORTABLE AND NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE LARGER IMPLICATION,
THAT LARGER FEELING THAT THE
FACT THAT THE COUNTRY IS COMING
DAYS OFF OF THIS SHOOTING.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO HOW THE VICTIMS
IN MICHIGAN OR OTHER PLACES
WOULD FEEL, FOLKS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED GUN VIOLENCE ABOUT
THAT PHOTO BUT I CAN SAY AS THE
SON OF A PASTOR WHO SPENT A LOT
OF CHRIS NTMASES AND CHRISTMAS
EVES LISTENING TO THE NATIVITY
STORY, I HAVE NEVER HEARD THE
CHRISTMAS STORY BE LINKED WITH
EXPLICIT POLITICAL ACTS LIKE
THIS, AND THE NEED FOR GUNS AND
WEAPONS.
THIS IS THEIR OWN VERSION OF
CHRISTMAS, AND THEIR OWN VERSION
OF A STORY THAT JUST SUITS THEIR
POLITICAL INTERESTS.
>> SPEAKING OF POLITICAL
INTERESTS, I WANT EVERYONE TO
LISTEN TO WHAT REPRESENTATIVE
DAN CRENSHAW SAID RECENTLY ABOUT
A WING OF HIS PARTY.
>> TWO TYPES OF MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, THERE'S PERFORMANCE
ARTISTS AND THERE'S LEGISLATORS,
NOW, THE PERFORMANCE ARTISTS ARE
THE ONES WHO GET ALL THE
ATTENTION, THE ONES YOU THINK
ARE MORE CONSERVATIVE BECAUSE
THEY KNOW HOW TO SAY SLOGANS
REAL WELL.
THE DRIFTERS IN OUR MIDST KNOW
THAT THE QUICKEST WAY TO YOUR
HEART IS TO CONVINCE YOU THAT
FELLOW CONSERVATIVES BETRAYED
THEM.
>> SPEAKING THERE AT THAT EVENT,
MATT GAETZ, OTHERS, LIZ CHENEY,
A CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN, HER
HOME STATE DOESN'T EVEN CONSIDER
HER A REPUBLICAN ANYMORE.
IT REALLY IS THE REDEFINING OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
CONSERVATIVE.
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND CRENSHAW IS
MAKING AN INTERESTING POINT IN
TRYING TO REFOCUS THE ENERGY,
SAYING YOU SHOULD LOOK AT PEOPLE
WHO ARE LEGISLATING YOUR
INTERESTING, KIND OF THAT MANTRA
OF GETTING BACK TO KIND OF CORE
CONSERVATIVE VALUES, THE PROBLEM
FOR HIM IS THIS IS A PARTY
THAT'S BEEN OVERTAKEN BY DONALD
TRUMP WHO IS THE BIGGEST EXAMPLE
OF SOMEONE WHO USED SLOGANS, AND
LANGUAGE AND, YOU KNOW,
CONTRADICTORY CONSERVATIVE
STANCES TO FIND HIS WAY INTO
POPULARITY OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, THE CONGRESSMAN THERE IS
TRYING TO FIGHT A WAR THAT HAS
ALREADY TAKEN PLACE.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP'S PARTY,
AND THE QUICKEST THING
REPUBLICANS CAN DO IN CONGRESS
OR TO RAISE THEIR NATIONAL
PROFILE TO FUND RAISE ON THAT
GRASS ROOTS LEVEL IS TO ALIGN
THEMSELVES WITH HIM, AND THAT IS
TOTALLY SEPARATE FROM
LEGISLATION, THAT'S TOTALLY
SEPARATE FROM POLICY MAKING.
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT IS THE
TRUMPY RHETORIC, ALIGNING WITH
HIM AND THEIR CULTURAL
GRIEVANCES, EVEN MORE SO THAN
ACTUALLY ENACTING POLICIES.
THEY'RE GOING TO RUN ON